[Music]  my name is patty high school was a  nightmare  sorry Betty's huge while my classmates  were out losing their virginity I was at  home stuffing another home smells like  bacon every day I wondered how much more  of this can I take then it hit me now  what where's patty right here  having my jaw wired shut lost me more  than just my summer vacation well this  is like every great high school movie  ever made  now I could be the former fatty who  turned into a brain or an athlete or a  princess no I'd rather have revenge  [Music]  out of control I want to punch her in  her [ __ ] face I want them to hurt like  I hurt  anymore I was insatiable what can I say  this story is full of some crazy  that's of  [Music]